ITS ALWAYS SAD WHEN SOMEONE DIES. HUH
THIS YOUNG MAN
WAS DRIVING DRUNK,
COMMA,
WITHOUT KNOWING
HOW TO DO IT PROPERLY. OK?
LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN.
THIS YOUNG MAN
WAS DRIVING DRUNK
WITHOUT HAVING PRACTICED
SO HE WOULD KNOW
HOW TO DO IT RIGHT.
AND YOU'RE NOT STUPID,
AND I'M NOT GONNA TREAT YOU
LIKE YOU ARE.
I'M GONNA TELL YOU SOMETHING
THAT'S PRETTY CONTROVERSIAL.
SOME PEOPLE DRIVE BETTER
WHEN THEY'RE INTOXICATED
THAN THEY DO
WHEN THEY'RE SOBER.
HI. MY NAME'S
DEPUTY JOHNSON.
I'M ABLE TO DO
SUCH A THING, ALL RIGHT?
THINK ABOUT IT.
MY DAY-TO-DAY LIFE,
WHEN I'M DRIVING,
WHAT AM I DOING?
I'M PLAYING AIR GUITAR?
MAYBE I'M TRYING
TO WIPE MUSTARD
OFF MY PANTS,
OR I'M TEXTING SOMEBODY,
BUT I'M SURE AS HELL
NOT LOOKING AT THE ROAD.
YES, I SAID HELL.
LIVE WITH IT.
WHEN I AM DRIVING DRUNK,
2 O'CLOCK. 10 O'CLOCK,
MIRROR, MIRROR,
EVERY 30 SECONDS.
THE AIR CONDITIONER'S
ON ME,
I'VE GOT
SOME SPEED METAL
ON THE RADIO,
I'M PUMPED.
I'M PAYING ATTENTION.
BELIEVE ME.
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS
SINCE I WAS 11 YEARS OLD.
I'M VERY GOOD AT IT.
IT'S LIKE USING CONDOMS,
OR POPPING
A PENICILLIN
BEFORE YOU HAVE
MULTIPLE ENCOUNTERS.
YOU KNOW? SAFETY.
YEAH?
I SEE A LOT OF
PRETTY GIRLS HERE TODAY...
A LOT OF PRETTY GIRLS.
SOME OF YOU HAVE
DEFINITELY GOT CAREERS
IN GENTLEMEN'S MAGAZINES
LATER ON
AND ADULT ENTERTAINING.
ALL RIGHT?
I HOPE THAT
WHEN IT COMES TIME
TO LIST YOUR TURN-OFFS,
THAT VEHICULAR
MANSLAUGHTER...
WILL BE ONE
OF THOSE TURN-OFFS.